two more women have come forward to say
the actions a former Vice President Joe
Biden has made them uneasy the claims by
four women in all have triggered a new
conversation about what is not
acceptable in the me2 era I think that
it's important for the vice president
others to understand is it isn't what
you intended it's how it was received
these women feel to me and that's not
okay
so if vice president buy does choose to
run for president the united states i
imagine this is a conversation he will
be having to have with the american
people any sort of harassment is
strictly wrong do you think this
qualifies as harassment
I like the motors make that choice I
think it goes to show that the times are
changing and people's expectations of
behavior are also changing and I say
that's to the good Joe Biden is not a
sexual predator this is no country for
creepy old men and and it needs to stop
Biden says quote not once never did I
believe that I acted inappropriately CBS
News contributor Jody Cantor is one of
the New York Times investigative
journalists who won numerous awards and
who broke the story on Hollywood mogul
Harvey Weinstein fueling the rise of the
me2 movement Jody good morning we should
point out Harvey Weinstein currently
facing charges accused of rape and other
dastardly crimes has the reckoning gone
too far
well the you know the tape that was just
played was great because it showed how
out sized this conversation has become
about Joe Biden and I think that's
because of three things this is drawing
on three very unresolved issues in the
wake of me - what are the day-to-day
rules for physical engagement even not
when we're talking about sexual
predation but sort of more regular
contact number two when somebody makes a
misstep how do you address it what's the
form of accountability what's the sort
of form of Correction probably the most
interesting word to me that has come out
of the Biden conversation is the word
disqualifying people have suggested that
this is actually disqualifying for the
presidency I think that's a very
controversial idea three who should the
Democratic nominee be for 2020 also a
very
unsettled issue and so all three of
those questions I think are kind of
converging in this debate I think do
these allegations though minimize the
more serious cases of assault and abuse
well we just have to draw a distinction
I mean a lot of these moments occurred
in public they occurred at events they
occurred in front of other people it's a
totally different scenario than somebody
like Harvey Weinstein who is accused of
drawing women into secluded places so
that he could take advantage of them
you've seen where these conversations
take place where they are done well and
handled intelligently and where they are
not is there a worst venue in which to
have these kinds of sensitive
conversations than a presidential
campaign but politics is always the
hardest venue it's the most important
venue because these jobs are the
definition of power but the hardest
Clinton Clarence Thomas Rhett Cavanaugh
Donald Trump every time we have debates
over whether over these men's conduct
they're very important but they also get
mixed with everybody's political
preferences and ideas about who they
want and not want who they do and don't
want to have power is this a
conversation about about age because
there were standards from a different
generation that are now under
investigation Joe Biden obviously will
be one of the older candidates running
and so is this a stalking horse also in
some cases perhaps for a conversation
about rage I think agent I think you
hear people saying that openly I mean
people some critics of Biden's behavior
on this count have essentially said this
is a sign that you are a dinosaur you've
already served your time in office I
want to see somebody nominated who
represents a present matter that Joe
Biden has been in public life for thirty
years that he was the architect of the
Violence Against Women Act does it
matter that dozens of women who worked
with him in the Obama administration
it's four years in closed settings say
he never touched me and or made me feel
uncomfortable none of this was sexual in
any nature Susan Rice today even
speaking about it well I'd take his
record on untrue policy issues towards
women matters a great deal and it's not
getting enough attention pro and con
people talk about his contribution to
the criminal justice issues you're
raising and there
a very critical of his conduct in the
Anita Hill case so there were pros and
cons of his record to be debated does
the whole conversation I have to say
Jodi makes me uncomfortable and actually
makes my teeth hurt have we gotten to
the point that we can't have any
physical contact with someone that we're
trying to be friendly with that we're
trying to be sympathetic with that we're
emphasizing with the fact that someone
kisses you on the back of your head or
rubs you on the back
shouldn't intention and motivation
matter and to your point it was all done
publicly well we are living through a
period of social change on these issues
which can feel very confusing to live
through but no less an authority than
Gloria Steinem had some advice in
today's papers she said the new rule is
if you want to hug somebody especially
somebody you don't know just ask first
pointed to a CEO of a major bank today
who told his wife I'm not gonna have
lunch with women anymore
well that's sad and that's unfair and
that's not right I mean I want to know I
mean what can happen but that is the
honest conversation that is happening
about backlash where men say I'm just
not even gonna do it because I'm being
accused of stuff that I have nothing and
so I'm just not gonna even go to lunch
with them anymore is that helpful
no and no say remember no no honest
about that that's an honest conversation
that's a heard that Jodi I you know I've
read a lot of our person what doesn't
mean to say that is right that doesn't
mean that that man is right but that is
that is true and that is happening you
know I think what we don't have a sense
of is how widespread that fear really is
and whether it's really hurting women
you hear it a lot you don't hear it on
the man we're not talking to enough men
because I think that fear is widespread
amongst men right but is it having real
consequences in the workplace is it a
worry or is it an action that I think is
very hard to know well it's something
you wouldn't do in front of your wife in
front of your daughter in front of your
sister you wouldn't have done to them I
think is a pretty good barometer there's
no need for people to be confused about
how to act approach your Biden is being
accused of doing it in front of I know
some people with cameras right now so we
should remember politics is just weird
people kiss babies yeah they don't know
funny but it's politics is also just a
very weird venue so anyway Jodi I'm
gonna have to kill it there that's
really Dodi's like this conversation you
guys like Thanks
i chained Thank You Harvey Thank You
Johnny thank you